i hate myself we're gonna have sex
do it usually the main character of the
show fleabag
is able to speak to or look directly at
the camera
without other characters noticing that
is
until this moment we lost a week
what was that suddenly this reliable
aspect of the show
is shattered but it's not the only
tenant that changes
in fact nearly all the rules of the show
fall apart
in this 10-minute sequence revealing
that these devices
are even more powerful when they're
taken away
understanding the way that these rules
break proves why there can never be
a third season of fleabag the 10-minute
sequence which occurs at the exact
center of season 2 starts at the end of
episode 3
with this conversation and continues
into episode 4.
fleabag and the priest go shopping go
for a walk
go to a silent quaker meeting walk some
more
and then have a conversation in fleabags
cafe there are three main devices that
make this sequence different from the
eight and a half episodes that lead up
to it
let's start with the most obvious
breaking the fourth wall
the way fleabag interacts with the
camera and the audience
is something that immediately sets the
show apart from everything else on tv
almost every conversation in the show is
interrupted by this device
we get so used to it that fleabag only
has to shoot us a look
and we know what she's thinking but as
the show goes on we get a better sense
of why she's so obsessed with talking to
and looking at us it's through her
closeness with us
that fleabag remains distanced from
other people
i have friends oh you do have someone to
talk to
yeah through the attention that she
gives the camera
she remains partially absent and
protected from her conversations with
other characters you're being
so quiet why aren't you saying anything
but in this moment the priest cuts
through this defense
where did you just go throughout the
10-minute sequence
as fleabag spends the day with the
priest she keeps us in the loop
but it gets harder for her to keep this
audience relationship secret
the longer she's with him take a look at
this exchange
it's nick fleabag says that to us
you never felt them go somewhere no they
were already gone
then she accidentally answers his
question to us
on his beautiful neck what and says
what's meant for us
directly to the priest
what he just said his beautiful neck the
sequence which traces the progression of
a relationship from distant
to close to uncomfortably close
challenges her to shed this defense
what is that
that thing that you're doing it's like
you disappear what
what are you not telling me nothing
talking to us prevents her from getting
too close to people
and this sequence strips that from her
but her asides aren't the only element
that breaks down
the editing style the show is known for
almost entirely disappears during this
sequence
the easiest way to get a sense of how
the show is usually shot and edited
is to look at the dinner scene at the
top of season 2. as the scene starts
there are 16 cuts in just 30 seconds
and 11 different types of shots compare
that to how this sequence begins
just three different shot types and only
six cuts in 30 seconds
now you might think this difference is
just because we're comparing a scene
with six people
to a scene with just two but even if you
dissect other two-person conversations
throughout the show
they look a lot more like the dinner
scene i need to speak to martin
martin martin martin why on earth would
you want to speak to martin
it's not just the speed of cuts that
changes during the sequence
it's also the style throughout the rest
of the show
editor gary dahlner uses jump cuts hard
audio cuts
and scene transitions that cut off
characters mid-word the most fascinating
thing about father here
is that his mother was originally a
lesbian
he also frequently cuts across the 180
degree line
breaking a filmmaking role that helps
maintain a clear sense of where
characters are positioned
in relation to each other in contrast
fleabag and the priest scenes during the
sequence
are framed and edited in a simpler more
fluid way
during the first two conversations in
the house and on the bench we get that
set up with three traditional shot types
one medium shot on each character and
one wide shot which
they share unlike the dinner scene the
camera remains on the same side of the
characters
following the 180 degree rule this
sequence also opens with a smooth audio
lead-in
so i read your book okay great well it's
got some great twists
when fleabag and the priest walk down
the street they spend a long time
sharing just this one camera angle from
the front
traditionally editors try to hide cuts
and make scenes feel seamless
but in fleabag cuts are jarring and
noticeable
fleabag is divided from the people
around her so the show's editing feels
fragmented too
but that all changes during the sequence
there's one final clue that this
sequence is operating differently than
the rest of the show
this is how the show flashes its title
throughout the second season
this is a love story
[Music]
this greek choral singing frequently
overlays fleabags thoughts about the
priest
it's a reverent catholic sounding theme
but it represents fleabag's desire to
violate a core
catholic principle using the sense of
irony
fleabag turns her interest in him into
just another inside joke with
us the audience oh god i fancy a priest
but look at the opening of episode 4
during the game-changing 10-minute
sequence
last one definitely yeah great
we hear music that is genuinely romantic
when she begins to care more about him
than she does about entertaining us
everything shifts so this sequence
stands out
but what's the point in changing the way
the show works for just 10 minutes
as slebag heals from grief her
dysfunctional relationship with the
audience
and the filmmaking language that
constitutes that relationship
transform that's why the show ends with
fleabag refusing
to let us follow behind her
this choice wouldn't be as striking
without her 10-minute day and night with
the priest
during fleabag's perfect sequence we get
a sense not just of why her relationship
with us has to end
but what it's been preventing her from
[Music]
seeing